I didn't realize this but you have a
background in musical theater I didn't
understand I'm sorry the original Rock
of Ages when it was a stage show I'd
yeah you were in the Tom Cruise role I
was I was so what do you mean you were
maybe a little bit of it you were in the
role of what's his name - mixtli or
mixed max Stacee Jaxx we're very close
to Meg's mix League who know movies
wanted to play max mixtli oh yeah he's
the rock and accountant hey guys can't
wait to do your taxes max but you were
so you were in this show and you're in
this state you were the stage version
yeah my friend Krista Renzo wrote wrote
it and so we put it up in LA for a
couple years and it was me and like Kyle
Gass from Tenacious D and Dan Finnerty
from the Dan band and then we did it and
then it went to Broadway and we couldn't
you know I couldn't go do it on Broadway
and then so they gave it to Tom Cruise
now were you at all jealous when it went
to Tom Cruise I wasn't you know I wasn't
jealous but it was I still haven't seen
the movie yet because the part for me is
this sounds so weird but it's like why
babe I was the first one so it's like
it's very special to me so I it feels
weird to watch the movie as almost it
like if someone said hey do you want to
pay 20 bucks to watch Tom Cruise your
ex-girlfriend I mean like oh yeah part
of me does sure
but maybe it's just so weird I don't
think it's like that at all
feel like it is literally exactly like
that well we have a picture of you as
Stacee Jaxx there yeah look at that
and here's Tom Cruise yeah there's his
version uh so does that bother you to
see him you did that off take that off
cone and take it off okay I loved how I
loved the response from zero of the
ladies after a siege tactics picture you
should have played Nick's mixtli
I should have done mixing the ladies
love mix next Lee let's get those 1040s
filled out yeah you um I wish that
hadn't been so high you started a
YouTube on YouTube network you've
started a sort of a bowling competition
is that right well I have I have this
there's a Nerdist channel which is a
channel the YouTube channel for nerds we
do a lot of fun like you know Neil
Patrick Harris is gonna do a show about
puppets with us and Neil deGrasse Tyson
is gonna do show about astrophysics with
us and and I am nerdy if my dad was a
professional bowler so I do this thing
called all star celebrity bowling which
is a charity team bowling competition
run get some really cool stars do you
yeah Cranston who was on your show last
night in Grant's Tomb
did making bad we did a Breaking Bad
team we did a Walking Dead team we did a
Mythbusters team we just did a Doctor
Who team and we did a Mad Men team with
Jon Hamm if it's a car thiser and
enriched summer and matthew whiner and
it was there were epic amounts of
heckling on that show epic amounts of
thing you can imagine yeah you know
maybe we'll get an E and I'll do it some
team Coco please please PLEASE bolo my
show now I can't you were too enthusiast
oh my god to excited and now I just
can't do it
Mel Andy you a good bowler and not
really oh good I'm terrible we're gonna
do it okay
come on legal contract yeah that's is
gonna I mix mix Lee I know how contracts